the National of regulations Emergency
Committee on Republic of Congo very
pleased to have with us today the chair
of the Emergency Committee
professor Robert Stefan also of course
director-general said one give the
answers and at his side today dr.
Michael Bryan executive director for the
WTO health emergencies program the
meeting started the Emergency Committee
meeting started today at 12 o clock
Geneva time the statements and the
recommendations will be emergency
meeting as today advise the
director-general to declare a public
health emergency of international
concern a thick what does that mean this
is still a regional emergency and by no
way a global threat and why this change
of opinion despite the collective effort
and particularly a tremendous support by
both the government of the Democratic
Republic of Congo and the commitment of
the people fighting in the field against
Ebola also despite significant
improvement in many places in a
tremendously complex situation now first
there is concern about spread of Ebola
from Roma to get away even though so far
no cases were newly infected in this
city - there is disappointment that has
been recurrent
of intense transmission in Benny so that
the geographical expansion is now some
500 kilometers for the fight is ongoing
for a full year now and lastly the
assassination of 2l of workers
demonstrates the continued risk to
responders due to security situation let
me underline that the thing is not
declared as a reflection on a suboptimal
performance of those active in the field
instance response teams or the
government of the DRC the rationale is
to better cope with the volatile
characteristics of this outbreak the
strategy is not to be changed we need to
intensify the actions also to become
more proactive in declaring a thing the
committee put at most emphasis that this
should not interfere with travel and
trade more than needed as per article 2
of the International Health Regulations
all actions must be commensurate
explicitly should be no closure of
borders by any of the neighboring
countries of the DRC or anywhere else
because that would have a terrible
impact on the economy of the affected
regions such impact would likely to have
negative consequences on the fight
against the outbreak the committee
reinforces the recommendations issued
during earlier Emergency Committee me
and also during the 2014 216 outbreak in
West Africa among the most important
preparedness must be enhanced in
neighboring countries so far there is
insufficient support for this complaint
actions list of all the recommendations
we'll find in your handouts finally the
committee is concerned that resources
have become a limiting factor in
technical assistance increasingly there
is lack of staff and of financial
support must be more engagement by the
global committee community to end this
outbreak thank you thank you thank you
and good evening everyone in the room
and everyone online and thank you
professor Steffen once again for your
leadership of the Emergency Committee as
well as all members of the committee and
the advisors and those who made
presentations during today's
deliberations as you know over the
weekend
a man from Bhutan Bo took a bus to gamma
a city of 2 million people on the border
with Rwanda and the Gateway to the rest
of DRC and the world on his arrival in
Roma the man a pastor visited a health
center when he was diagnosed with Ebola
he has since died separately last
Thursday a woman with Ebola symptoms
from DRC cross the border to buy fish at
a market in Uganda on Friday she was
diagnosed with Ebola and treated in DRC
she too has died although there is no
evidence yet of local transmission in
either go
or Uganda these two events represent a
concerning geographical expansion of the
virus as a result of this concern for
potential further spread the committee
recommended that I declared the outbreak
a public health emergency of
international concern thing and I have
accepted that advice our risk assessment
remains that the risk of spread in DRC
and the region remains very high and the
risk of spread outside the region
remains low I have also accepted the
committee's recommendations for PRC its
neighbours and all countries which can
read in the statement in particular I
emphasize that that nature does not
recommend any restrictions on travel or
trend which rather than stopping Ebola
can actually hamper the fight
closing borders could have disastrous
consequences for their lives and
livelihoods of the people who cross the
border every day for trade education or
to visit relatives site restrictions
forced people to use informal and
unmonitored border crossings increasing
the potential for the spread of disease
they will also serve no useful purpose
already that had been more than 75
million screen screenings for Ebola
abroad at border crossings and other
checkpoints we call on all countries
companies and individuals to support DRC
by respecting those recommendations now
is the time for the international
community to stand in solidarity with
the people of the Democratic Republic of
Congo not to impose punitive and count
productive restrictions that will only
serve to isolate them the government of
DRC is showing exceptional transparency
in sharing information every single day
it was the DRC government which informed
Uganda about the family with which cross
with Ebola that crossed the border last
month it was the government of DRC that
informed the international community
immediately last week that there was a
case in common the government of DRC is
doing everything it can they need the
support of the international community I
stress this the government of DRC is
doing everything it can they need the
support of the international community
that includes its financial support as
we said very clearly after the last
Emergency Committee meeting a fig is not
for fundraising it's for preventing the
International spread of the disease
whu-oh is not aware of any donor that
has withheld funding because of because
a thief had not been declared but if
that was the excuse it can no longer be
used we are now finalizing the false
strategic response plan for this
outbreak which will outline the
resources needed for the next phase of
the response we don't have an exact son
yet but it will run to the hundreds of
millions unless the international
community steps up and funds the
response now we will be paying for this
outbreak for a long time to come finally
I want to comment the government of the
I see for its commitment and cooperation
and through His Excellency the president
who has visited the affected areas and
has formed an inter-ministerial
committee to ensure the whole government
is focused on the response I also want
to honor the hundreds of responders from
the government partners and our own
staff who as we speak are putting
themselves in harm's way to serve others
more than ever they need our support
I thank you take questions from the
journalists we will start with three
questions from the room and at this
meantime those who are online if you
type 0 1 on your touch pad you can get
into the queue for questions we'll start
from the room please
[Music]
why did problems as you said to number
one recognizes the increased production
from the company and doubling production
for 2020 but also recognizes that we
have attack mmm
limitation of supply we wouldn't have
been involved in adjusted doses if we
had adequate supplies of vaccine
available right now so accelerating the
availability of vaccine is a priority
and
i director-general's had discussions
with senior representatives of the
manufacturers to discuss options for
that which could include increased
production by the manufacturer or
arrangements made with contracting
manufacturers who could produce the
vaccine on behalf of the company or
through a licensed agreement with that
company and those discussions are
underway and with regard to the other
vaccines the Sage has recommended the
introduction of a second vaccine the
double Joe still supports the
introduction of a second vaccine subject
to the approvals of national regulatory
and ethical committees and we have
worked very closely with the J&J
consortium on planning for the
introduction of that vaccine as that
vaccine has considered through the Dacia
review by WHR to be the most likely
candidate to be deployable in the field
and an effective manner in the real time
and that the scale and the amount that
will be needed those discussions are
underway with the Ministry of Health and
with the principal investigator INR be
in-country and yes the the ministry has
expressed concerns about introducing a
second vaccine which are mainly around
the issues of confusion in the local
population we're working through those
issues about where and when the vaccine
could be used and how which protocol
will be used under but just to state for
the record the vho still supports the
introduction of a second vaccine in line
with the sage recommendations but
subject to the appropriate national
approvals
program another question from ASP here
in the room what exactly happen here I
mean you paid it the other day and now
what happens now automatically war
resources more funding question
on the funding first of all we thank
those contributing resources but as we
have been saying many times we shouldn't
leave these public health emergency of
international concern the declaration
with intent mobilize resources financing
actually should be available to prevent
outbreaks financing should be available
to prevent the feet from happening
financing should be for preparedness
financing should give to fix the roof
before the raining hands so we don't
want to associate feet or the emergency
declaration with
the resource mobilization but it was a
coincidence that even before this there
was renewed commitment to finance and we
hope that will continue whether its fate
with regard to vaccine effectiveness the
impact of vaccination I think there are
two separate issues here one is the
efficacy of the vaccine itself which has
been proven in the field the vaccine
protects individuals against disease the
other issue is what proportion of people
who need the vaccine are getting the
vaccine which is about are we detecting
every case are we detecting those cases
in time are we starting vaccination in
the context and context in time so this
response and all responses still rely on
the core shoe-leather surveillance
detection community engagement community
acceptance and many of the factors so
vaccination can only be completely
effective in the context of an effective
surveillance operation within an
accepting community a huge amount of
work is done going to improve our
surveillance performance and as you've
seen under the leadership of UNICEF to
improve and deepen community engagement
and acceptance with the three together I
believe we are making progress and we've
in the last five to six weeks we've seen
the highest number of rings started in
the shortest time since the beginning of
the outbreak so we're making significant
operational progress but notwithstanding
the new risks that have been detailed by
the emergency committee vaccines what
has changed
now nothing is as cheap I think the
Ministry of Health in Congo have looked
up to proposed protocols they have
concerns regarding the introduction of
the vaccine that vaccine into the
epidemic zones they still remain open to
the hang of schemes that will allow the
vaccine to be deployed in the field and
used in areas not yet affected by the
epidemic we believe there's still the
possibility that
yeah thank you Thank You Helen you know
the not only the recommendations of
today but since the outbreak started we
were advising neighboring countries and
others that because of the Ebola
outbreak to make no restrictions of
trade or travel and with this thing what
we are telling what we are telling the
world is that it will actually be having
repercussions if there is restriction of
thread and mobility and it's actually
through open door policy we can control
the outbreak better and I said it
earlier the government is actually
leading and also cooperating there is a
daily report from the government of the
RC on the Ebola outbreak situation but
not only that it was the DRC government
that had notified Uganda of the crossing
of the cases and Uganda was able to
finish the cases as as soon as I mean
the avoided the local transmission from
establishing itself in Uganda
immediately and not only that gamez case
was reported by the government
immediately so when there is
transparency when there is cooperation
we have seen how helpful actually is to
follow open-door policy and not only
that on borders the points checkpoints
more than 75 million people scream and
this is helping some cases were detected
during crossing so when it's working
well we don't need to do anything
different that implicate that affects
the response negatively but having said
this if countries make
regions of course we will talk to the
country in question and try to help them
to understand but at the same time we
have we will make all our communications
see that they are 22 suspected cases in
I understood that you said that there
are four now but we actually think the
first thing to say is that the teams in
Goma and there are over 650 responders
on the ground in Goma as we speak
including 50 w-h-o staff i was
specifically assigned to Ebola we've
been preparing in Goma as the DG is
referred to previously for well over six
months as part of that process we
generate daily alerts of suspect cases
so suspect case definition is very broad
it's very sensitive and therefore we're
picking up suspect cases every day
and to date none have been positive
apart from the pastor we've also
vaccinated 257 people as context and
context of contacts in Goma so we've
taken a very broad approach to the
context of context of found travelers
who were on the bus with pastors there's
been extensive vaccination of contacts
and context of context of the parent of
the pastor there are no other cases in
association with that
there are no other people meeting the
case definition as part of that
transmission chain we will remain alert
and vigilant so again it's important
there are many alerts every day in Goma
and there have been for many months that
shows the system is working some of
those are considered suspect cases they
are taken to an each of you in a Transit
Center where they are tested they have
tail all tested negative so far over the
last six months apart from the pastor
who tested negative after being
transferred immediately from the first
Health Center II visitors within one
hour of presenting at that Center so
what Goma has demonstrated is like
Uganda has that preparedness works
unless the DG said this is we need to
[Music]
thank you
a couple of questions in there part of
the casting which is the core public
health operation will cost has been
casted in excess of two hundred and
thirty three million dollars but those
figures are being finalized and tweaked
at the moment so we're talking in that
range so that's the the number on that
it was difficult to understand the first
part of your question yes the ultimate
goal is zero case of course it's
confined now the outbreak is confined in
the two provinces of eatery and North
kevo but with a very high risk of spread
to neighboring provinces and also
regionally so our aim is to finish this
outbreak and our aim is
[Music]
have you received it's not promised that
actually received from the World Bank
and do you think that now that you're
declaring a fight the World Bank will
finally release its pandemic fund for
you from the World Bank but other
agencies have received funds through the
pandemic emergency fund cash window it
was so far to my knowledge 20 million
dollars has been released by the
pandemic emergency phone cash window of
which has been divided 6.5 million for
w-h-o and 13.5 million for for a unicef
unit the World Bank though has been
working with the government on
reallocation of existing idea phones a
country level but you'd have to follow
up with them to get the exact numbers
and apologies in the region for your
action again what do you think can be
done to reduce the level of violence in
do you think that the government to
restore security and if not do you
personally think that you may or may
help some other country like that an
example
a question for dr. Ryan I'm the security
problem in North Kibo has been there for
many years now more than 25 years so
it's not new it's a war zone and that's
why one of the reasons that's why
actually we were not able to control the
outbreak fully until now it's almost a
year because it's a war zone and the
other problem is the political tension
also you see in that region so these are
the complicating factors that fuels the
outbreak itself as you know when there
is a security problem the response is
disrupted and when the response is
disrupted the virus gets advantage and
propagates and whenever we make progress
when there is a security problem that
then we lose all the progress we made so
this was what you see in the curve of
the epidemiology curve actually up and
down up and down so the security problem
is serious of course there was an
incidence a few days ago and to
community health workers Congolese were
killed but the last seven six weeks has
been relatively stable and one of the
reasons for this is the Congolese army
and the Monaco UN troops are working in
coordination and they have coordinated
command center and that's helping and
they are trying to prevent any attacks
but in addition to that I think the
renewed community engagement is also
helping with community ownership there
could be more security and stability
because some of the the attacks were
coming actually from community members
when they were angry because they were
excluded from
election during last year's election so
the security problem has many reasons
behind it and addressing all those will
be important at the UN Security Council
I think we have given a briefing twice
and the third one will be on July 31st
and especially with regard to security
we will expect the support of the UN
Security Council because this is a
chronic problem that will need the
attention of the international community
but led by the government the government
is doing its best and also helping the
rest of our lives
there will be outbreaks and a moment
when the world should look at this and
say we really need to
you know the addressing the root causes
is the best solution actually it's a
political problem or a security problem
that's behind the Ebola Ebola is a
symptom there is measles outbreak that
is chikungunya outbreak as we speak
there is cholera outbreak as if it's not
enough then you have Ebola and when
there is you know a complicated root
cause that affects the whole system the
social economic and political situation
and then you will have such problems so
addressing the root cause as you said is
obviously the most important solution
but at the same time while addressing
the root cause of the problem we have to
also use you know whatever we have to
fight the existing outbreak but we made
a call a few weeks ago as you may
remember and we have invited the
international community to help DRC and
other countries to address the root
cause of the problem take the Yemen for
instance there is cholera outbreak as as
we speak many new generation in Yemen
and never had any knowledge of Cholera
twas a forgotten thing but with the war
and destruction of the infrastructure
cholera outbreak which is the largest
modern history has engulfed Yemen so
addressing the root causes is key and
the world as an international community
actually should should help countries to
address the root cause and not only
focusing on Ebola and other humanitarian
support but linking the development or
the already been introduced in ministry
and that currently is we've reduced the
dose to the guinea dose in other words
it's half the original dose which is the
same dose that was used in the efficacy
trials and Guinea which proved
efficacious based on the advice of our
sage committee we're confident in the
use of that adjusted dose any further
reduction of adjustment of of the dose
will be carried out under the guidance
of the same sage process and we have a
special Ebola virus disease working
group of our sage committee which is
keeping this under constant review we
would not make any further those
adjustments unless the epidemiologic
situation indicated that we needed to
expand the amount of available doses
obviously the best solution for this
problem is a ramp up and production
Vicky Vicky
[Music]
growling the eastern Congo how the
government of Rwanda Uganda given the
WHL any assurance that going forward
they won't environment any travel or
trade restrictions what I know is Rwanda
and Uganda have been cooperating
actually because both sides of the
border the same families and that's
their principle to keep them to stay
together it's actually the same family
on both sides of the border and that's
what they you know we know was in Grande
and Uganda and we know and we hope that
will continue thank you very much to
protect us with this we have to close I
thank everybody who has been waiting
patiently online also for the apologies
against for the delay of half an hour
into the press conference thank you for
a journalist here in the room
thank you chair of the Emergency
Committee professor Stefan dr. Ted was
and dr. Mike Ryan I wish you all good
evening thank you